un moteur des rétroviseurs un toit en
panneaux solaires
mathieu chanfreau assembler un vélo pas
comme les autres c'est un vélo à trois
roues que j'ai acheté d'occasion
également que j'ai électrifié avec une
entreprise qui dans le sud de la france
qui s'appelle déclic échos qui m'a bien
bien aidés qui m'a aidé aussi pour le
tout la partie support des panneaux et
puis le test je les fais il ya deux
jours seulement donc juste deux semaines
avant de partir en corse un bolide qui
servira à faire le tour de la corse dès
le 13 mai prochain
700 kilomètres en une semaine pour un
dénivelé global de 10000 m en attendant
son départ mathieu s'exerce à la
maîtrise de son nouveau vélo vélo
électrique m'a redonné goût au vélo m'a
remis en forme aujourd'hui je fais des
distance de 80 km en vtt que je faisais
pas avant
donc ça marche dans les deux sens en
fait on peut passer du vélo électrique
au vélo bio et du vélo bio à
l'électrique
une expédition pensait en novembre
dernier avec un ami dans laquelle il
manquait quelque chose
moi il me manquait une dimension un peu
humaines dimension utile à ce projet là
et donc j'ai parlé à nico j'avais
vraiment envie de d'essayer de trouver
quelqu'un pour qu'on pût campus suite
aidé en fait pas forcément une grosse
association un peu impersonnel mais
quelqu'un dans notre entourage dans
notre village et c'est un peu le hasard
ou je sais pas ça s'est passé un peu
naturellement deux jours après je
tombais sur un poste de sur facebook
2ème ligne mais qui est la maman d'une
petite fille polyhandicapée dans jouars
pontchartrain dans un mot qui est juste
à côté
et donc j'ai pris contact tout de suite
et on s'est vu le lendemain et basse a
accroché mathieu a décidé d'utiliser son
projet pour médiatiser la maladie de lou
6 ans atteinte du syndrome de rett
c'est la maladie qui touche le plus de
petites filles en france le côté sportif
nous a tout de suite plu parce qu'on est
on est une famille de sportifs
on a été un petit peu bloquée par le
handicap de loups pour pouvoir faire
plein de choses et malgré trois
handicaps c'est vrai qu'on fait encore
beaucoup de sorties vélo donc en fait on
accroche sa poussette au vélo de ludovic
la plupart du temps une cagnotte
participative a été mise en place pour
soutenir les traitements rares et
coûteux de loups le premier palier à
2000 euros pour un fauteuil permettant
alloue une assise confortable a été
atteint maintenant la cagnotte
participative aide au financement de
l'école équithérapie un ensemble de
soins physiques et mentaux par les
chevaux